nein nein scharf direkte weg weg weg weg
danke auch man ich möchte auch irgendwas
finden ich glaub mich gerade pampa ich
finde gar nicht ein theoretisch mich
durch durch comics mir hätte auch etwas
deutschen ich will endlich mal was
cooles finden
ich baue mich irgendwie muss ich mir
naja ich muss hier alles ausschlachten
dann irgendwie hoch und dann so und so
war jetzt hier noch irgendwas nein es
gibt sachen diesem spiel die fehlen
aber ich sage nicht was denn sonst ist
ihr ein geheimplan afrika ist eigentlich
dass man nicht keine spinnen hat weil
sonst könnte man sich mega viel zu holen
und dann nähe und dann so tripwire fall
machen
wie findet ihr denn was ich bin einfach
nach unten gegangen
begraben oder was ja ach so ich habe
einfach gewartet sagt mir das doch jetzt
greife ich einfach nach unten
ich finde wenn ich epic traurig wir
haben noch alle 10 13 minuten und 1319
mächtig stress war nicht so leid ich
habe das gefühl ich gefunden habe ich
weiß nicht warum aber warum er war ich
weiß gar nicht was das habe ich auch
schon vorher gefunden hatte ich auch was
kann ich denn jetzt noch zu machen ich
finde ja auch gar nichts ich werde ihr
habt viel coolere welt 90 ich glaube es
auch gar nicht
aber ich werde ich scheitere trotzdem an
irgendwas erbärmlichen wir machen jetzt
eigentlich der kämpfen wir bei allem
oder schmuck
jeder selber entscheiden mit meinen
jetzt in den reitern fertig bestimmt in
den nahkampf gehen soviel kann ich sagen
die schon mal kein problem mit ich auch
nicht lange kämpfen und dann wird das
ein unendlich langes projekt genau das
was spaß
sag ich nur dass hier kommuniziere
heimlich mit meinen zuschauern über den
chat besagt dass deine zuschauer sind
meine und während ich noch dein video
fällt bei mir sagen jetzt dass ich so
von der kag bin weil ich alles über sehe
aber ich sehe einfach mal gar nichts
außer gras und als scheiß schaaf hätte
für euch am besten dreifach zu kräften
obwohl jetzt schon namhaft jetzt einfach
noch mal machen soll ich kann jetzt mehr
als nur erkennen wo er schon mal ich
mach trikot action wenn man oben kräftig
eine reise kannst du doch auch nur
finden weil federn kriegt man die
überhaupt noch auswählen ja doch kriegt
man aber bei mir jetzt zu gucken ist so
langweilig bei mir auch ich glaube mich
einfach nur um mich auszuruhen oder hier
bei mir geradezu guckt warum machst du
das eigentlich wer gerade weg öfter der
dom zukunft der kommt einfach mal zu mir
rüber
nein nicht sein doch ziemlich uncool
naja ihn einfach alle zu den da können
wir irgendwie auch mussten aber dann
kriegt ja nicht so ein geiles game wie
wir hier aber ich glaube nicht rückwärts
aus wolle doch mal kriegt federn aus
hühnern übrigens kriegt man auswahl
rückwärts wieder sein
dann brauche ich eigentlich nicht das
was wollt ihr denn mit seilen frage die
die ganze zeit als die uci
tipps darf man ja markt geben ich bin 99
trifft ja ich hab die wenig haben
richtig fit werden was zur treppe sage
ich euch jetzt nicht weil es zu viel
neues zu sagen da meine mutter meine
zuschauer die nur hier sind wegen mir
ist das
auf der gesamten länge der mauer rein
oder nur an bestimmten stellen wie jetzt
die baustelle geht unter
da kann man einfach durch ja das ist
komplett weg
toll was bringt mir die sonne ändert
wenn hier bin ich dringend ab
naja du kein deponieren es ist sicher es
ist sicher vor den anderen
ach so ja ganz nett dackels zu einem
kannst du da die sachen von ihm abziehen
sozusagen als offene e mail erstmal mit
ein bisschen was wenn wir nochmal das
brauchen was in chat geschrieben haben
gehen wir noch mal runter und holen
lover von mir aber ich wette mal bei uns
wird meint bietet die wenigsten aufrufe
haben ne wobei weil die leute einfach
mal mich sehen wollen oder mit axt aber
wahrscheinlich werden sie einfach
einsehen dass bei beiden zumindestens
nichts los sondern seine donnerstags bei
dem es immer gut gespielt
ich glaube sollte lustig sein
lock and load ich möchte auch so toll
moment haben wo ich sagen kann ja jetzt
mache ich davon dann mach ich ja
überhaupt nicht ehrlich gesagt es kann
und jetzt jetzt setze ich meinen plan in
gang
jack im boden käme schon ein mieser ich
mache auch in diesen plan aber ich wette
dass es so ein mieser plan dass er gar
nicht aufgehen wird weil ihr dann
eigentlich drauf reinfällt
ich habe mein kleid kaputt gemacht ok
gleich wieder an täglich plan das
wachstum an meine zuschauer bitte jetzt
nicht meckern das ist das erste mal dass
ich so was im wie mache also mein erstes
mal erst mal
die sind auch teilweise echt komisch
gänge aber ich habe das gefühl an ärzten
kannst du nur kohle und eisen finden das
auch kein laub slutzky ja eigentlich
deutschen wollten das schöne design dies
dass irgendwas bauen
ja ich sagte ich wollte doch die seiner
haut waren aber ohne lobby ist schlecht
ich tue etwas gefunden ich hab was
gefunden
warum soll ich jetzt machen als ehrlich
was man emerald finden kann
da habe ich mich dann auch gefragt was
was will man damit das ist ich glaube
das ist schlechter witz mit wem somit
den handel der fand es toll weil das
eine 1.3 war ich glaube auch dass alle
sehen er hat irgendwo in einer höhle in
weniger versteckt haben werde ich noch
18 13 uhr so seien erst dann wenn
theoretischen schafe bande tripwire
dingen 20 schafft dann ist es alles
ausgelöst
da stand nur monster ausmachen
da wollte ich mir sagt wie man sich ein
scheiß bogen kräfte ich habe mir noch
nie ich habe vielleicht hätte ich noch
1.15 gezockt haben brauchen mal gekracht
hey du hast gesagt du hättest du lieben
ich habe gesagt dass ich von einer sache
drei habe ich habe nicht gesagt dass
drei wirken habe macht das schwert
aquino ein trikot der kann mir noch mal
bitte sagen wie viel zeit wir noch haben
13 war es eben noch diese diese klopp
bin ich irgendwie cool clean gehört mit
dieser kreis kompakt dass diese diese
glocke also diese counter ich weiß was
ich hatte weniger macht einmal trasse
nicht zum grab geworden oder nein ich
weiß trotzdem was du machst was ich
mache sie garantiert dispenser gemacht
was will ich damit filzens damit mit
pfeilen im g abschließen stimmt ich noch
gar nicht gedacht
hier saß dem tipp gegeben natürlich
nicht
die habe ich einen test gemacht
das kann noch irgendwie das ist doch bin
ich blöd aber scheint so ok nich schritt
nicht antworten
das ist daher theoretisch ich bin einer
von euch klar allah und nix passiert ja
alles okay denn so auch nicht sein dass
wie deaktiviert ist
nein du musst es mit feuerzeug oder
redstone aktivieren wir denn sonst
rechtsklick oder so ich mache ich mache
das letzte stück auf dass es endlich
hell wird um bahn gilt als licht kommt
rein
so weiter er findet epi coole sachen
torjäger eine wenn hier der [ __ ] vom
dienst ich bin [ __ ] 2 vom dienst ich
find auch nix lasst uns zusammen
august vom dienst sein beruf mango wie
verpacke ich das jetzt dass er darauf
reinfällt
ich glaube ich viel zu viel über meine
vorhaben wahrscheinlich ich habe schon
eine gute idee
die wird zumindest ein kind wenn ich es
hinkriege gekriegt bekommst es aber
nicht hin
in meinem leben jemand mitbekommt dass
wert auf einem 1 1 gefallen man noch
zwei anfallen video mit aufrufen und den
leuten gefällt das aber ganz ehrlich
aber auch fallen
wer baut sowas alter frage wer braucht
sowas möglich leuten gefällt hat auf ich
habe meinen chapman table im inventar
auch wirklich ihren jobs die nicht sogar
was soll das denn heißen sogar kontrakte
nein weil du die ganze zeit eher
meintest du das auch irgendwo funktionen
fast länger jetzt ist auch eine stadt in
sachen hier in erinnert es heißt du bist
also nach hamburg
zum glück hat das jetzt nicht
funktioniert was ich hier gerade gemacht
habe welche ganze alles in der luft
geflogen
das wäre überhaupt nicht gut gewesen
alter ich wäre froh wenn nicht
wenigstens irgendwas hätte was so
ähnlich aussieht wie tnt
wenn ich dann meinen draußen bin egal
wohin trete ich habe verlangt dass
irgendwas jetzt gleich explodiert sei
alles erfolg betrieb vorher gemacht die
ganze karte damit überspannt alles
zugemacht zu gesponnen und ja ich habe
überlegt ob ich irgendwie alles mit
obsidian zu bauen so richtig bock habe
ich auch nicht 20.000 mal mit einmal
runter zu laufen alter gefunden
nein nein schaaf schaaf direkte weg weg
weg weg danke ich weiß bei der alten
version gab es irgendwie sowas im hügel
arbeit in diesem hügel ist glaube ich
nicht da gab es auch schon einen gang zu
also ich hab mir die map gar nicht
angeguckt ich weiß gar nicht kannte
die alte habe dich mal könnt ihr jetzt
einen gemeinen sich ein scheiß burg
machte ich verspreche wird keines
händler machen
denn nur was haben was ich in der hand
halten kann was leute ich bin halt nicht
der punkt ich bin mir so ich bin als
special agent michael sogar prototyp ist
korrekt
je mehr so in den nahkampf danach klappt
mit einem nahkampf staffel mit meinem
nach kapstadt 30 minuten so richtig
schön lagen was ist gar nicht lang ist
da nicht lang allein das gebrauchen
könnt ihr mal seine andacht ist das
sechs oder sieben oder neun von harnik
an x7 centers
machen wollte krieges behandelt zeit gar
nicht was ich machen will ich auch nicht
ich laufe einfach nur rum da war auf
einmal ein paar bei den anderen cook bei
den anderen korrekt nicht gucken wie
steht konnten
ich brauch mal was zu essen das ist so
viel ist sicher
ich sollte mal was zu essen aber ich
benutze es nicht an ich mache ich so was
wie tnt nur heftiger newcastle halt nix
unnötige scheiß sagt stefan raab mut
macht man ja noch mal das niemand gibt
es das schon etwas anders aus
man darf doch selber im internet
anschauen oder nein nein das ist elfter
du kannst den zuschauern so sieht man
das bei den nicht oder was ich noch mit
raps auf ja und das ist dem zweiten
bildschirm oder fehler mit fraps das
wählt ein bildschirm all das wird ein
fenster aus also minecraft ja was davor
selbst und nimmst du nicht in f11 auf ok
es sei ja meine aufnahme ist gefällt
warum weil einfach aufgehört hat
aufzunehmen dann startet sie wieder
erstes für eine mango scheiße wie kann
das sein dann muss auf die taste
gekommen sei
irgendwelche post 1 ist die letzte taste
auf dich kommen würde natürlich einfach
auf 9 genommen wie sie gesagt habe weil
ich hatte schon mal auf 9 und dann hatte
ich wollte ich im programm aufnimmt in
dem programm während hotkey alles
finanziert ich habe mein job mit table
ach du scheiße jetzt bis zu spät nämlich
nur noch ich kenne die zeit ich lese ich
glaub's 5 egal nimm einfach naja ich
nehms jetzt wieder auf bitte ja ich
nehme jetzt wieder auf ist alles egal
man hat nicht viel verpasst weil sie ja
nicht er aber deine festplatte ist nicht
vorher meine festplatte ist nicht für
das was ich vielleicht ist post einzelne
kunde taste kann gut sein macht mir dann
noch mal als es für den arsch warum
benutzen wir fraps weil es funktioniert
dass fünf richtig benutzt was einzelne
scheiß dass ab jetzt hatte ich das 1
welche fällig die taste ändern ach das
ist so eine sichere nummer